[Music]
okay you look a little smitten right now
I don't know I'm smitten with Maisie I'm
smitten with Maisie chills my wife can
we talk about the fact that amazing is
joining the Marvel verse just like you
if we don't get a crossover on Game of
Thrones
getting one on x-men okay
she's joining x-men New Mutants what
advice do you have for her to be joining
this brand-new franchise oh wow I mean
she kind of cooled me out the Davis she
was offered it and she was like what do
I do like what should I do and I was
like taking it 100% it's gonna be the
best thing for you but my advice to her
would be like you feel like an idiot
doing it you're doing it right because
being a mutant you have to do the
craziest like [ __ ] your hands and
transforming into things and you feel
like an idiot doing it but it's gonna
look awesome when it comes out what's
the CGI's in there it's gonna be great
Maisie
you've got a new x-men movie coming out
right now what can you tease about your
journey
I can choose nothing I really I have
like they're gonna kill me if I choose
anything well here's a question for you
who is more concerned about Secrets Game
of Thrones or Marvel Oh God
both of them have like snipers on my
back right I can't reveal anything about
either they're crazy
lockdown it's so lockdown but it's more
exciting for the fans that way right
weird if you have a brand new game of
Thrones after show called Westeros
sweetly and we have a running segment
called the Starks sister update no.1
where each week we give an update have
they seen each other and then we just
say no no
that's amazing I like that can you give
us a Stark sister update no I mean it
would be amazing if they were to
crossover at some point but I think we
have more chance in the Marvel Universe
in Game of Thrones because we're not
about happy endings on Game of Thrones